la cadence l'effort et la bonne fatigue
olivier retrouve les joies du rameur
pour la première fois depuis sa perte de
vue suite à une opération
il était venu pour se prouver qu'il
avait les capacités de se remettre en
selle le coach qu'il assiste le pousse à
redoubler d'ambition ram et un jour sur
un bateau tu as bien fait tout à fait
possible pour toi olivier
d'aller d'aller sur le bas côté à côté
là on pourrait être mettre dedans et
puis s'il est très stable il ya des
utilisateurs sur les côtés donc il n'ya
pas de souci pour la stabilité on a
juste à de concentrer sur le sur la
propulsion du bateau chaud déplacement
du bo
pour encourager la pratique du
handisport la pf france handicap a
imaginé cette journée découverte au menu
aviron tennis de table cyclisme ou
encore tir à l'arc beaucoup de personnes
en situation de handicap vont pas
pratiquer des activités sportives parce
qu'il pense ne pas être capable de lui
connaissent pas forcément les
adaptations qui existent donc là l'idée
c'était de pouvoir rassembler toute une
majeure partie des associations qui
organisent des créneaux adaptées aux
situations de handicap physique et leur
montrer que ba éventuellement ils sont
capables de faire des choses une
question de volonté plus que de moyens
c'est aussi le constat du directeur
adjoint du creps de bourges selon lui
les structures adaptées aux handisports
existe mais il manque encore de
visibilité
il ya déjà les relais des deux
fédérations qui s'occupe des personnes
en situation d'handicap donc handisport
et sport adapté avec ensuite leurs
antennes régionales et leurs antennes
départementales et les clubs locaux
voilà les clubs locaux de ces
fédérations oeuvre aussi auprès des
établissements où des différentes
structures pour pouvoir communiquer
auprès des gens au terme de cette
journée les organisateurs espèrent avoir
convaincu un maximum de personnes
handicapées d'intégrer un club de sport
adapté leur situation